[Music]
what's going on guys welcome back to the
channel
today we have this 2017
uh it's a ford f-150 and today we're
going to program a new key for this
truck so as you can see here i have
the original key
i'm going to use the
key that i want to program we already
actually cut this key
and
let me just show you that it doesn't
turn on the truck
so
what we're gonna use today to program
these two keys
um
we're gonna use the autel uh 608
so here we have the information already
pre-selected on this truck and now i'm
gonna take you we actually are gonna
need the first original key
to open the switch
and
we are going to
scan the immobilizer to see how many
keys we have programmed because you can
program uh only up to eight
and we should see only like four or two
already programmed so we have two
from the factory
uh we're gonna add a key
we're gonna select key guided automatic
we're gonna
start and it's gonna say if the factor
alarm is activated you need to
deactivate it first so
we don't have that activated so we're
getting uh press yes
and select yes
it is normal that the instrument cluster
is gonna flash sometimes because of the
programming function so we press insert
the key to be learned and turn the
ignition on so we're gonna remove the
key
and we're gonna insert the key we want
to
learn
we're gonna press okay
it's gonna enter the system and it's
gonna require about three to ten minutes
sometimes it takes less time but
let's just wait in and see what happens
okay so that was quicker than i thought
it took only a minute so we're going to
press ok
turn ignition off
we're going to press ok again
insert the key to mid learn and turn
ignition on
press ok learning key
and we successfully learned the key as
you heard the the log cycle and that
means the key is already programmed so
we don't want to program another key
we
we're gonna go back escape
and now we're gonna test the key
so we see here it's working
and now let's go i'm gonna test the
other one
so both keys work
and
now
let's rescan the system make sure we
have the key already programmed so we're
gonna do a mobilizer scan again
and let's just wait let's just wait for
codes probably i'm gonna have full court
no
we're good uh and now we have three keys
already programmed all right so this is
pretty much how you do it it's really
simple with this tool uh with other
tools takes like 10 minutes but with
this one
it's an amazing amazing tool a little
bit pricey but it's worth
buying this tool because you can do so
much work with this all right guys so i
hope you liked the video please if you
haven't subscribed subscribe to the
channel like the video dislike if you
didn't like the video comment down below
turn on notifications also so you can be
updated with every video i upload every
week alright guys thank you again for
watching and see you on the next episode
bye
[Music]
you